[Music]
where did you grow up I grew up in
Detroit Michigan you grew up in Detroit
yeah they're white so suburbs of Detroit
all right so you grew up in a mixed-race
yeah my parents were mixed we're
interaction my mom was white my dad was
black and my mom's like this little this
sweet little kind of elven white lady
from Northern Illinois and from a
farming community in Northern Illinois
but she's like down for the black cause
big-time you know right and so when we
were kids we used to watch I'd watch the
news with my mom and like the news would
come and they'd say a man was a tuck
today on the 7000 block of st. Aubyn and
my mother would look at the TV and go
please be white please be white please
be white like not the man who got
attacked but the perpetrator the
perpetrator was please be white please
be white please don't be black it's
really for the really for the dogs for
the black people you just seen are all
my family parties just just acres and
acres of afros and this little white
lady bobbing around you know you are
correct you are a trained mind yeah I
took mine in graduate school why would
you do that it was it was required of us
and Andy knows that what in improv we
call mime object work because it sounds
so much cooler than mine that's right I
don't understood some object work just
don't some object work you know but why
is it called object work instead of
because like if that cup you know like
you were gonna pretend there's a cup in
an improv scene right you would you
would it's an object so I'm going to
pick up the object and place the object
down and glom off of the object that's
called glomming you glom on and you
climb off if you glom on and put it down
and go like this you're a ghost yeah so
I call that picking up and putting down
okay but you just naturally glommed what
no yeah you natural air glom you know I
did something improv back in the day I
know how when you pick up a cup one of
the big rules is then you have that cup
you have yeah you're you gotta then put
it back down again in response a so
that's practically you were see would
you like my hair
No
oh and there's my vacuum that was a cup
of acid
isn't improv nothing better Paige so
well you made millions of dollars of
mine so yeah that's I would think that'd
be the hardest thing is it and you got
you don't do any of that stuff that day
you never did that we all what we did
was like we did undulation that was the
big thing we've all been that was just
talking about undulation yeah and we do
all this stuff where you had to learn
how to move the different part you were
doing it earlier yeah yeah your body's
like you know like if you're gonna go
around a wall or a pole like you have to
hold the pole and you have to move like
this around the pole and all this kind
of stuff so we did a lot of this stuff
in mind class a lot of this jazz yeah
thank you hit on it and it was uh it was
a lot of that go over in Detroit they
come back home for Christmas you better
not threaten me because here's my
shotgun
[Laughter]